Hey everyone, this is Mark Wiens with Eating
Thai Food dot com.
Today I'm at one of the ultimate vegetarian
food courts in Bangkok, it's called Baan Suan
Pai, also known as Banana Family Park.
Of course, if you're vegetarian or vegan you're
going to absolutely love this place, but the
food is so good here, you'll want to eat here
even if you're a carnivore.
To get to Baan Suan Pai take the BTS to Ari
station, take exit number one and go down
the stairs to your left, walk along Phahon
Yothin road for about one hundred meters until
you reach a sign that says welcome to banana
family park.
Turn right into the small cafe alley way,
walk all the way to the back past a few coffee
shops and a few stores until you can smell
the delicious vegetarian food.
It's like a food court style, so you order
your food here and then you go sit at a table.
As you can see, I went a little crazy, but
the food all looked so good that you can easily
accumulate a bunch of different things.
I'm going to go through the food right now
and show you exactly what I ordered.
I got a dish, it's a curry made with pumpkin.
Bitterness is an excellent flavor but it does
take a little getting used to.
Ohh, I love that.
This is called puak tod, and this is taro
ground up and then it's fried on the outside
into a loaf.
Add some of this sauce.
Got a quick dish here called kuay teow lui
suan, it's like a noodle wrapper filled with
lettuce, some herbs, I think there's some
tofu and mushrooms in that.
It's very fresh, the sweet and sour and spicy
sauce is fantastic.
This is probably my favorite thing at this
whole restaurant, these beautiful skewers
of steak.
No they're not steak actually, they are mushrooms.
I just wanted to mention the vegetarian Thai
food guide.
It's an eighty page ebook stuffed with useful
information and tips about how you can order
and eat tastiest vegetarian and vegan food
that Thailand has to offer.
If you're vegetarian, if you're vegan, or
even if you just want to start eating healthy
delicious Thai food, make sure you get your
own copy of the vegetarian Thai food guide,
so you can take advantage of this awesome
food, it's just incredible.
Anyways, as you can see, I still have a bunch
of food left on the table, I'm about to dig
in and finish it all.
I finished off all of the food except for
this last bite which is the last remaining
piece of het hom ping, the absolute sirloin
kobe beef of all mushrooms and it's fully
vegetarian.
It just melts in your mouth, it's juicy, it's
tender, that will put a smile on your face
any day.
Thanks for watching this video, when you're
in Thailand make sure you eat and sample all
kinds of delicious Thai vegetarian food and
don't forget to check out the vegetarian Thai
food guide!